[Music]
the revolt over woke leaders growing
louder across the country la's radical
district attorney george gascon
making pathetic excuses on why he went
easy on a criminal gang member turned
cop killer the suspect got probation
instead of jail for a 2020 drug and gun
arrest which freed him up to murder two
police officers last week
the history of the suspect mr flores
did not contain any evidence of violence
i urge everyone
to ensure that we do not overreact here
and that we do the things that we know
that work the possession of a gun is not
considered a violent crime simple
possession of a gun is not considered a
violent crime okay
he was arrested for possession of drugs
in possession of a gun not the use of a
gun
under the circumstances i believe that
was an appropriate outcome this is not
about explaining this is simply about
clearing the record
and over in philly calls are growing to
impeach their radical d.a larry krasner
family members of victims are now
joining republicans saying they need to
get rid of the guy dana talking with a
mother who blames the d.a for her son's
murder
i come from a bipartisan approach
i want
everyone to come together collectively
whatever needs to be done whatever
changes need to take place
we need this so
if it starts with impeachment and to
have um mr kirsner out of the office to
bring someone else in to effectively
protect the people the citizens of
philadelphia then i then by all means
necessary because we're tired of losing
our children our loved ones in the
streets of philadelphia
was that an emotional interview for you
of course yes i mean um so one thing's
about that story is that her son
was at the mall
and he was there to buy a new pair of
pants and he needed a new pair of pants
because he was going to a job interview
and so he was trying to do the right
thing that's terrible right and so he
was he had his life together he was on
his way and there is a suspect that was
let go
and i think that one of the things
that's interesting about this whole
thing in philadelphia and let's put
california in there as well as the
recall that in philadelphia some of the
democrats are saying well this is just a
republican-led effort and dismissing it
that way but i think even though the
republicans in the state legislature had
put it forward what they've done is to
allow the victims and the victims family
the victims families to be the ones that
do the talking so at the press
conference if you watch all of that it's
there's no republican talking point that
you can find in it it is just the raw
grief of parents and siblings aunts and
uncles grandparents who are desperate
for some sort of answer and as you heard
nakisha say she doesn't it's not it's
not partisan for her and i i think if
we're actually going to get this solved
that somebody like gascon when he gets
up there he goes to do a press
conference but he doesn't take any
questions he ignored matt finn's
questions he can't defend you can't
defend yourself by just getting up there
and saying i think it was appropriate
and that's the end of that and walk off
were you buying gus guns
defense judge up there at the podium
what do you think tell me why what was
he splitting hairs and dissembling over
this charge splitting hairs the man's an
idiot this guy flores is a career felon
he was a felon who instead of being
given prison time for the third time
he's already served two prison terms and
understand there's a difference between
a prison term and a jail term we're
talking state time all right this guy is
a gang banger he's a career criminal
he's spent most of his life committing
crimes and the amazing part of it is
he's not only arrested with the with a
gun but a gun and ammunition okay he
wasn't using the gun what was the ammo
for was he going to sell it on a street
corner that is a dirt bag who belongs in
jail and it's gascon's fault that he
killed two cops and i got news for you
they will lie to your face these
progressives and tell you we've got to
start with this social justice nonsense
look this is nothing new we've known
from the 90s there's only one way to
keep us safe and that's to put criminals
in jail who look to harm us that's why
we had three strikes and you're out and
in chicago the latest the latest is they
don't want cops chasing criminals on
foot and lori lightfoot really wants you
to believe that she's worried about the
cops getting home safe so don't you dare
chase these dirt bags on foot
do you understand what the strategy is
if you don't want foot pursuits that i
mean you can't even do car pursuits in
some precincts and now they don't want
you to chase on foot what do you think
is going to happen i'm as confused as
you are
the good thing about all of this is that
voters will have an opportunity to weigh
in here
i was i was shocked that mr gascon whom
i don't know
would hold a press conference to defend
to justify to
i guess give some explanation as to why
he let this man out
if you're serious about protecting the
community you should held held a press
conference saying we're going to change
this law
and we're going to have a different
approach here in this office because uh
the law
he claimed that the law forced him to
let this guy out no he's wrong that's a
lie
he's a third time are you yelling at me
i'm with you i'm saying
i'm just but no we don't need to change
the law the law is there he's not
enforcing it right so what i would have
said was we're going to change our
position in this office what he did
there was an affront uh to the police
officers who were killed and their
families um the san francisco recall is
a lesson to every d.a in this country
even our own d.a here in new york
voters want safe and secure
neighborhoods and if you don't give it
to him you will likely be recalled and
brian if you saw the mug shot the guy
has i think i counted three to four
facial tattoos right and i mean i throw
the book at him just for that right he's
not he's one he's a member of those
non-violent gangs yeah so they're
they're brought up everywhere
they get together it's basically a book
club right where they compare tattoos
and they read out loud to each other
right so uh so this guy was oh the guy
who his probation officer said you know
i think he violated probation by
threatening his domestic partner so i
think we should start pulling him in
next thing you know the police get
called because uh the woman he's with
says he pulled it pulled a gun on her
they show up and a knife on her and they
show up and they get gunned down he ends
up putting a gun into his mouth and he
kills himself i love the lori lightfoot
thing we don't want cops chasing down
people unless of course uh they're for
felons okay fine so that'll save
hamstrings for police officers around
the globe who don't get a chance to
stretch before they uh chase down a
criminal but it just gets to show you if
you're not running from chicago right
now you're not keeping your best
interest in mind pack up your family get
the bubble wrap out and run for your
lives because the cops aren't helping
you they're not allowed right you don't
even need good cardio to be a criminal
john right away
it's true i went on brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now